good afternoon everyone and welcome to
today's covet 19 update as always we
have dr dina hinshaw chief medical
officer of health for alberta dr hinshaw
thank you chris and good afternoon
everyone
before i start i would like to provide
two updates
first i would like to provide an update
to our outbreak reporting
on thursday we advise that due to ahs
focusing their resources on
investigating high risk outbreaks we
would need to adjust our public outbreak
reporting to just continuing an acute
care sites
however in further conversations with
ahs they have confirmed that at this
time they are also able to continue to
provide us with complete outbreak data
for congregate living facilities such as
correctional facilities and shelters
as such these will again be listed on
our outbreak list beginning today
we understand albertans have become
accustomed to having regular access to
covet information
and we appreciate everyone's patience as
we make adjustments due to the omicron
situation
it's also important to remember why
outbreaks are not being reported in
other contexts
first of all given the very high number
of cases in the community and the fact
that most cases in fully immunized
people are mild and can be managed at
home
outbreak activities that were used
earlier in the pandemic such as
individual case tracking and contact
tracing are no longer warranted for most
workplaces
outbreak responses by public health are
now focused on the highest risk settings
where there are populations at increased
risk of severe outcomes particularly
acute care and seniors congregate care
facilities
these are settings that would typically
have outbreaks managed for other
respiratory viruses including seasonal
influenza because of the risk of severe
outcomes
other workplaces should follow the
guidance that is available on bizconnect
as well as general public health
recommendations such as physical
distancing and masking to help prevent
spread of covid19
as we look at continuing care and the
impacts of the omicron wave we continue
to emphasize the need to protect
residents in these settings from
multiple health risks
including the direct risk of covit
the health risks of social isolation and
disconnection
and the risks of having insufficient
care providers to meet their basic care
needs
these risks sometimes compete and we
have no single straightforward path to
perfectly meet all these needs
simultaneously
we must continue to seek balance
we have communicated details to
continuing care operators today on how
some of the recent changes to case
management relate to residents of
different care settings
for example as was announced on january
3rd the shortened isolation period for
fully immunized cases does not apply to
residents of designated supportive
living facilities hospices or long-term
care
these individuals must still isolate for
10 days if they get coveted
this is because people living in these
types of facilities are at higher risk
of severe illness from covid19
we have also recently heard concerns
from some of our partners about the
timing for rescinding the single site
worker order in continuing care
we are currently working through a
process to ensure an orderly return to
work at multiple sites for staff and
employers by february 16 2022
this process was developed over the
summer and fall of 2021 in consultation
with union and labor representatives and
continuing care association
and operator representatives and the
approved process was communicated in
december
input from staff residents and families
was also sought by a town hall meetings
and surveys as a part of the planning
process
it has always been critical through this
whole time to work closely with all our
partners
next week we will again be meeting with
all stakeholders to ensure they have
opportunities to provide additional
input on the process that is underway
and the impacts of the current omicron
situation on that process
turning to today's numbers
over the last 24 hours we have
identified about
3279 new cases of covet 19
and completed about
8995 tests
our positivity rate for lab confirmed
cases is 38.8 percent
there are currently
1089 people with covid19 in hospital
including 104 in the icu
our analytics team has been working hard
with alberta health services to provide
a robust summary of the proportion of
new hospital admissions that are due to
covet as compared to admissions because
of other causes
we will provide this information on our
website later this week but for the time
being a summary is being included as a
part of my weekday twitter account
updates
our most recent data from new admissions
since late last week indicates that 51
of new admissions to non-icu spaces
are due to covet infection
and 49 are cases where the infection was
not determined to be a cause of
admission or where it was not possible
to determine
for icu the percentage of new admissions
due to covid was 74
and 26 were incidental on infections or
unclear
this is a different trend than what we
have seen with previous variants and it
is due to the much higher
transmissibility of omicron
we're providing this data to inform
planning and in alignment with other
provinces reporting
however it is important to recognize
that any covet covered positive
admission has an impact on our acute
care capacity
additional care and isolation protocols
need to be implemented for all coveted
positive patients to prevent the risk of
transmission to other patients who are
at risk for severe outcomes
it's also true that someone may be
admitted to hospital for another reason
but a coven infection can complicate
their stay and their clinical outcome
the bottom line is that our acute care
system remains under serious pressure
and covid19 continues to pose a risk of
severe outcomes to many albertans
sadly i must announce that nine new
deaths have been reported to alberta
health over the last 24 hours
my sympathies go out to the family and
friends who have lost someone no matter
the cause
as we continue to see omicron is highly
transmissible and the province is seeing
a rapidly increasing number
of cases
we are beginning to see our
hospitalizations follow suit
on sunday our hospitalization surpassed
1 000 total for the first time since
october 14th
even if we take into account the
proportion of these that are admissions
for other causes with an incidental
covet infection
the overall burden on the system is
large and growing
this rise will continue to put pressure
on our health system and the health care
workers who take care of us
this affects all of us
even if we do not personally become ill
with covid19 we each continue to have
regular non-coveted medical needs and
any one of us could need urgent care
when we least expect it
the decisions we make now and the steps
we take each day
are critical to ensure the healthcare we
need is available when we need it and
where we need it
while we continue to learn about the
omicron variant
we have long known how to prevent
infection and limit spread and those
steps are still relevant today
we know to stay home if we're feeling
sick to physically distance reduce
social contacts to wear a mask in public
and to follow all public health measures
every day we also know how important it
is to get our vaccines not only first
and second doses but whatever additional
doses were eligible for
for a majority of the province that
would include a third dose but given
that immunocompromised individuals do
not develop the same levels of immunity
after vaccination
we are moving to make fourth doses
available to these people
three doses is in fact considered to be
a primary vaccine series for someone who
is immunocompromised
in terms of comparing the level of
protection to an average person without
immunocompromising conditions
given this providing a fourth dose to
these individuals is equivalent to a
third dose for others there are
approximately eighty thousand
immunocompromised albertans who were
eligible to get their third dose in
september of twenty twenty one
this means that many of them are soon
reaching the five month mark after that
third dose
both the national advisory committee on
immunization and the alberta advisory
committee on immunization have
recommended that immunocompromised
individuals age 18 and over receive a
fourth dose of covid19 vaccine
this is why beginning this thursday
january 20th we're opening up booking
opportunities for immunocompromised
adult albertans to receive a fourth dose
of covid19 vaccine at least five months
after their third
fourth doses will help those who are
immunocompromised to have the same level
of immunity as those of us who are
receiving our third dose and who are not
immunocompromised
this will not only help prevent some
breakthrough infections that we've been
seeing but also decrease the chance that
people with immune compromising
conditions could have severe outcomes
from covid19
the list of conditions eligible for a
fourth dose remain the same as those who
are eligible for a third dose due to a
clinical diagnosis or treatment in
september of 2021
you can visit alberta.ca to review that
list
to be clear fourth doses are only
recommended at this time for those who
have these specific medical conditions
and are immunocompromised
others who do not have these clinical
conditions are not eligible for forth
doses
even if they're nearing five months from
a third dose they may have received for
travel purposes
individuals with immunocompromising
conditions may still have some risk even
with this fourth dose
we must continue to work together to
ensure those most vulnerable in our
communities are protected
the current variant is highly infectious
and some may even be wondering if it's
inevitable if they will get it
i would like to remind people of the
reason that omicron appears to be milder
which is largely because of vaccines
vaccines dramatically reduce the risk of
severe outcomes even as we have seen
some waning of protection against
infection
even with vaccines getting sick with
covet is not a common cold
you cannot predict how far your
infection will spread through others
through an ongoing chain of transmission
or who it will reach
unfortunately at some point it will
likely reach someone for whom covet 19
is not a mild illness
so for those people i am asking all
albertans to remain vigilant
we are all connected to each other those
we know and those we don't know and the
actions we take every day make a
difference
thank you and i'm happy to take
questions
thank you dr hinshaw we'll now move to
the q a portion of the update operator
can you put through the first caller
please
yes hi there um i wanted to ask you
about billa keratin
and the explosion of cases that's
occurred there over the past nine days
115 patients and 10 staff and two deaf
what is alberta health doing to try and
curb this
outbreak and do you think enough is
being done
with respect to specific individual
outbreaks the supports for those
outbreaks are provided by alberta health
services to the organizations
so unfortunately i don't have the
details of all the individual outbreaks
that are happening right now certainly
we have seen some continuing care
outbreaks with larger numbers of cases
to date we have not seen the same impact
of severe outcomes that we've seen in
previous waves however it is early
and we continue to monitor closely if
you want specific information about how
that outbreak is being managed i would
recommend talking to either the operator
or alberta health services may have
information on the public health
supports that are being provided because
this would be one of those
higher risk settings for which alberta
health services is providing that full
public health support
do you have a
follow-up yes i do thank you very much
someone on social media indicated that
at villa characters last week that the
staff were still wearing medical masks
rather than n95
given that dr teresa tam as well as the
cdc have recommended n95 in high risk
settings would you concur that perhaps
n95 would be a better option for those
staff members
we have updated our
requirements for continuing care to
indicate that when
caring for an individual with a probable
or confirmed
case of covid
that staff in addition to all of the
other ppe masks do not work by
themselves so ppe does need to include
other aspects such as a face shield
and gown and gloves in addition to that
kn 95 or n95 mask would be considered
the minimum requirement for those
settings in general when someone is
working in those settings and not
providing care to an individual who is a
suspect or confirmed case they would of
course need to always do a point of care
risk assessment as is required for all
settings but in general the minimum
requirement for those settings would be
a high quality well fitting medical mask
for the routine continuous masking and
again the n95 and kn 95
would be the requirement for settings
when dealing with a suspect or confirmed
covet case
operator can you put through the next
caller please
brianna carson smith global
hi dr hinsha i wanted to ask you about
hospitalizations
uh and dr bernie used op-ed that was
posted today she said that albert health
services is increasing icu capacity can
you tell me what that looks like how
many beds uh who will staff those beds
and are there plans to ask other
provinces or the military for help
i don't have details about alberta
health services acute care planning so
it probably would be best to direct
those specific questions to alberta
health services
it is clear that
to date our omicron pressures on acute
care have been greater in
the non-icu part of acute care rather
than icu
and so of course
we're working closely with alberta
health services in terms of looking to
what the the possible trajectories might
be and
supporting them with with data however
again those details of the specific
acute care preparations ahs would be
best positioned to speak to
and ultimately what all of us can do to
minimize that impact on the health care
system is to do everything we can to
prevent transmission in our communities
brianna do you have a follow-up
yeah we're getting really close to our
record high of hospitalization so how
close are we to needing redeployment
mandated overtime or postponed surgery
again i'm sorry i'm not part of the the
detailed internal planning that happens
within alberta health services on that
acute care planning so those specific
questions are probably best to direct to
alberta health services
operator can you put through the next
caller please
jason herring post media
hi dr hinshaw last week dr bonnie henry
said bc has likely hit its peak in
copenhagen infections for the omicron
wave but that hospital emissions are
expected to continue to rise in the
weeks ahead
where do you believe alberta currently
is in the trajectory of our omicron wave
it's difficult to say we know that other
jurisdictions have seen uh that have
been ahead of us with omicron have seen
their cases peak around four to five
weeks from the start of the the surge
we when we look at our wastewater data
there are some locations where we are
seeing a bit of a lowering of the
wastewater
concentration of the virus but other
places where we're still seeing a rise
so one thing to keep in mind is that it
will be slightly different in different
areas of the province
but
certainly it's possible that we could be
seeing
a
plateau or kind of reaching that that
peak within the next several weeks
it's always true with every wave that
hospitalizations continue to rise after
the peak of cases and we have not uh
seen that peak of acute care impact and
again we are there there's no definitive
proof that we are currently at the peak
so we do need to continue to watch and
it's also important to remember that
half of the cases that happen in a wave
happen on the second side of the peak
which means that everything that we do
to minimize transmission
whether it's before the peak or
immediately after still matters and it
matters until that transmission has
dropped to very low levels so our
actions are important
again whether or not we reach the peak
in the in the next week or so
jason do you have a follow-up
yeah thanks um i'm wondering what the
current number of healthcare workers is
who are off due to covid19 illness or
exposure and what impact it's having in
patient care and if you're unable to
answer the question since it pertains to
uh ahs acute care operations
i'm wondering if the province will
commit to making dr verney you available
on upcoming covid19 press conferences to
seal these types of questions
an important question and you're right i
don't have that information as it is
more operational um i also am not part
of the conversations about who attends
these press conferences uh but certainly
that question
is something that our communications
team can consider but again
unfortunately i i personally don't have
the ability to make those decisions
operator please put through the next
caller
lauren poland global calgary
hi dr hinshaw just following up on some
of these hospitalization related
questions i do understand that
a lot of them are under ahs protocol but
we are at a point right now
where uh the situation is actually less
people in hospital a little more in icu
than when we saw these levers pulled
last time of redeployment of postponing
surgeries and procedures
again i understand that you don't have
it on hand
but any information for albertans on if
we could see this happen could surgeries
be postponed could procedures be
postponed and and how are we going to
staff this if we do get to that level
unfortunately again that the details of
staffing aren't things i could comment
on but it is absolutely clear that as
the burden of acute care
rises with respect to coveted missions
that postponement of surgeries or other
procedures that are non-urgent
is absolutely something that
is possible as the system makes space
for the need to care for patients who
who have covid and again even those who
are admitted for other reasons
but have a covet infection
need to have additional protocols to
prevent spread of infection so there are
still impacts in terms of capacity even
with those patients so again
absolutely there could be an impact on
surgeries and other procedures
the details unfortunately would have to
be something ahs could comment on
lauren do you have a follow-up
i do thank you
we are now uh in the fifth wave of this
uh we have hit record hospitalizations
during the fourth wave as well can you
explain to me how did we get to this
point again and do you take any
responsibility for what led us here
i think that one of the major factors is
the high transmissibility of the omicron
variant
the question about the progression of
the wave certainly in every wave we've
had
we've seen
a
series of
points in time where the situation is
assessed
i have provided
recommendations along the way
and so the the decisions about
managing cases managing the wave i can't
speak
on behalf of elected officials about
decisions all i can say is that
omicron is more challenging than
anything we have dealt with before that
it is more transmissible it does cause
more breakthrough infections
and that
the decisions about managing that
pressure again are not mine to make
operator please put through the next
caller
dylan short post media
hi dr hinshaw looking at third dose
booster numbers
it looks like alberta is lagging a
little behind other major population
provinces we also saw this with first
and second dose uptake i was just
wondering
why do you think albertans may be a
little bit slower to to get their
vaccinations in other parts of the
country
it's difficult to speculate
certainly when polling has been done
looking at the intentions of albertans
to get vaccine
there has been
a sometimes a lower percentage in
alberta than other provinces what we've
seen historically is that although
initially there's been a slower uptake
there has been an increase over time so
i would encourage those you know
albertans may be
wondering if they need a third dose
or wondering if omicron is mild is it
really important to get that third dose
and i would say to those who are
contemplating or wondering first of all
again the reason omicron is mild is
because we have high vaccine coverage
and so the fact that someone who gets a
breakthrough infection doesn't end up as
often needing hospital care
is exactly because the vaccines are
providing that severe outcome protection
and that third doses not only improve
that severe outcome protection they also
help reduce the risk of infection which
means that people who get a third dose
are contributing to that protection for
their community and minimizing the
chance of onward spread so it does
remain very important and i would
encourage albertans who don't have that
protection for themselves and their
community to take the first available
opportunity to get it dylan do you have
a follow-up
yeah i know that there's been a lot of
you know messaging and a lot of talks as
well as making vaccines uh available at
pharmacies and at clinics and in
different community places
but in earlier ways we saw a number of
other initiatives whether that was the
the lottery or you know as payments to
encourage people to go get those doses i
guess is there are any of those previous
incentives or other incentives that we
haven't
looked at before
are any of those being discussed at this
time as whether to bring them in to
encourage more third dose update
it's important to consider how we can
encourage that third dose uptake
certainly the
the incentives that were used earlier um
i'm not aware that they're going to be
brought back but uh i do think it's
important that we look at all the ways
that we can encourage albertans to get
the protection of that third dose
and what might be feasible at this time
we have time for two more questions
operator can you put through the next
caller please
matt woodman ctv
hi dr hinshaw we're hearing from
healthcare workers that non-icu space is
becoming tough to manage just based on
the sheer number of patients and staff
shortages what is your message to
healthcare staff and what should they be
prepared for in the coming weeks
my first message to healthcare staff is
that i recognize that this is just the
latest onslaught in what has been a very
very long
series of waves and that i can only
imagine how tired they are and
that this current wave is just adding to
an already significant level of fatigue
so
i would say
how much their efforts are appreciated
but also that uh
that appreciation can only go so far
when when they are day in and day out
having to manage this pressure
i think that the
coming weeks will involve increasing
burdens on our acute care
because we know that it does take
several weeks after a peak of cases to
see the peak of impact in our acute care
system so whether it's icu beds or
non-icu beds i would say to those who
are working in the system on the front
line
thank you and unfortunately we do need
to prepare for this to get worse before
it gets better
matt do you have a follow-up
do uh do you foresee a day when uh the
province is encouraging uh regular
alberts people who don't have uh and you
know compromise conditions do you
foresee a day when you're encouraging
them to get a fourth dose
it's difficult to say we've seen some
other countries make that decision but
we haven't seen data that would indicate
that that fourth dose
is necessary at this point in time for
average albertans as we have always done
we will continue to closely monitor the
data and determine what is
recommended with respect to
any additional doses
but at the moment we are seeing again
that severe outcome protection is
significant even with two doses it's
better with three and while there can be
some breakthrough infection that that
severe outcome protection is one of the
most important things that vaccines
provide so again we'll continue to
monitor the data and as evidence emerges
we will use that to incorporate into our
program
operator please put through our last
caller
david staples edmonton journal
hi dr hinshaw thank you for taking my
call
um
you talked about uh the new numbers on
um new patients coming into the hospital
and kind of like about a half of them
are there because of covet and half with
cloved what is a
of those numbers what
how how would that play out in the
system why do we need to know that kind
of thing
we know that in past waves when we've
looked back about uh
you know 90 or more of the cases that we
have been documenting with admissions
are
directly due to that covet infection and
this is different so we need to document
this now because omicron is different
and because
it's important for us to be looking at
our system
impacts looking ahead i want to be clear
that that 50 percent is only for those
who are not going into icu
where it is an icu admission the number
is much higher so we're looking at
something closer to 70 75 percent
so
um again it's it's to be able to provide
people with an understanding of of what
the direct and indirect burdens are and
also for us to be able to plan what the
impact could be for again the direct
covid caused hospitalizations because
omicron is very different from other
viruses virus variants that we have
dealt with in the past we do need this
kind of data to help us adjust our
forward projections
and
of course feel that it's important to
make it available to the public as well
david you have a follow-up
yeah for example if omicron continues to
take over from delta and there's fewer
and fewer delta cases more and more
omicron cases
would that give you and if the omicron
cases for instance are less likely to be
because of covet in the hospital or
because of coveting itu
would that then give you an idea that
we're going to have even though we might
have higher case counts we might have
fewer people in hospital or in icu if
omicron takes over more and more from
delta
we certainly are seeing omicron as
the vast majority of our cases right now
so
looking at
greater than 95 percent of the cases
that
are screened are
omicron so right now we are in that
situation in terms of omicron being the
majority of the new cases
and
certainly again for those projections it
does matter the
anticipated
impact of where those cases end up and
it does seem that with omicron we are
seeing that that lower
individual severe risk although i want
to emphasize that at a population level
there is still a significant burden on
the on the health care system and we
should not take this lightly but we do
need to understand those specific ratios
so that it can help us
plan for and prepare for what we think
that acute care system impact will be
thank you everyone that concludes
today's covet 19 update
we will be available for the next one
later in the week thank you have a good
day